sur les neuf médailles individuelles six
ont été obtenus par des athlètes
québécois pourquoi ça va si bien
début de réponse michel rochât les
soeurs dufour-lapointe ont fait la
fierté des québécois cinq semaines et
elles ne sont pas seules six médailles
et divi duel sur 9 pour le canada
proviennent d' athlètes québécois
comment expliquer ce succès un ensemble
de facteurs selon sports québec qui
débute par le recrutement
je pense qu'il faut aussi voir dans les
performances des québécois le fruit d'un
système un système qui permet de
détecter le talent je pense aux jeux du
québec la presque totalité des québécois
qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui à sotchi a
passé par les jeunes ce qui est après
avoir repéré il est plus prometteur on
les encadre avec des programmes sport
études
on a aussi mis en place au québec des
programmes sport études qui permettent à
l'individu de s'épanouir donc d'acquérir
ses compétences sportives bien sûr mais
aussi poursuivre son cheminement
académique on ceux qui accèdent au
niveau donne un pied en devenir
ils ont ensuite accès à une enveloppe de
près de 5 millions $ du programme
provincial
équipe québec un programme qui existe
depuis 2003 avec le programme équipe
québec c'est extraordinaire oui on
supporte les athlètes d'une façon
financières mais également supporter les
entraîneurs ça c'est la clé je pense si
on veut former des athlètes on doit
supporter nos internautes
de plus les athlètes québécois
bénéficient d'argent du fédéral par le
biais du programme à nous le podium et
d'infrastructures nationales également
comme la patinoire de vitesse courte
piste
reste à voir au final si les québécois
maintiendrons cette cadence à vancouver
en 2010 il avait récolté un peu moins de
la moitié des médailles individuelles
canadienne ici michel rochon radio
canada montréal